determine whether 380 is divisible by 2
3 4 5 6 9 or 10 they skipped 7 & 8 so we
don't have to worry about those so let's
think about 2 so let's think about
so are we divisible by 2 let me write
the 2 here divisible by 2 well in order
for something to be divisible by 2 it
has to be an even number and to be an
even number your ones digits so let me
read that rewrite 380 to be even your
ones digit has to be even so then this
has to be even and for this to be even
it has to be 0 2 4 6 or 8 and this is 0
so 380 is even which means it is
divisible by 2
so it works with 2 so 2 works out let's
think about the situation 4 3 now a
quick way to think about 3 so let me
write just 3 question mark is to add the
digits of your number and if the sum
that you get is divisible by 3 then you
are divisible by 3 so let's try to do
that so 380 let's add the digits 3 plus
8 plus 0 is equal to 3 plus 8 is 11 plus
0 is so it's just 11 and if you have
trouble with figuring out with a
dissident like 3 you could then just add
these two numbers again so you can
actually add the 1 plus 1 again and you
would get a 2 regardless of whether you
look at the 11 or the 2 neither of these
are divisible by 3 so not not divisible
visible 5/3 maybe in a future video I'll
explain why this works and maybe you
want to think about why this works so
these aren't divisible by 3 so three
hundred eighty so three hundred and
eighty is not divisible 380 not not
divisible by three so three does not
work we are not divisible by three now
let's think about the situation let's
think about the situation for 4 so if
we're thinking about 4
divisibility so let me write it in
orange so we are wondering about for now
something you may or may not already
realize is that 100 is divisible by 4 it
goes evenly so this is 380
so the 300 is divisible by 4
so we just have to figure out whether
the left over whether the 80 is
divisible by 4 another way to think
about it is are the last two digits last
two digits divisible by 4 and this comes
from the fact that 100 is divisible by 4
so everything on the hundreds place were
above it's going to be the life or you
just have to worry about the last part
so in this situation is 80 divisible by
4 now you could I ball that you could
say well 8 is definitely divisible by 4
or 80 divided by 8 divided by 4 is 2 80
divided by 4 is 20 so this works yes yes
so since 80 is divisible by 4 380 is
also divisible by 4 so 4 works for work
so let's do 5 make sure you scroll down
a little bit let's try 5 so what's the
pattern when something is divisible by 5
let's do the multiples of 5 5 10 15 20
25 so if something is divisible by 5 I
could keep going so divisible by 5 that
means it ends with either a 5 or a 0
right every multiple of 5 either has a 5
or a 0 in the ones place so 5 or 0 in
ones place ones place now 380 has a 0 in
the ones place so it is divisible by 5
now let's think about the situation for
6 let's think about what happens with 6
so we want to know are we divisible by 6
so to be divisible by 6 you have to be
divisible by the things that make up 6
remember 6 is equal to 2 times 3 so if
you're divisible by 6 that means you're
divisible by
- and you are divisible by three if
you're divisible by both 2 and 3 you
will be divisible by 6
now 380 is divisible by 2
but we've already established that it is
not divisible by 3 if it's not divisible
by 3 it cannot be divisible by 6 so this
gets knocked out we are not divisible by
6 now let's go to 9 let's go to 9 so
divisibility by 9 so you can make a
similar argument here that if if
something is not divisible by 3 there's
no way it's going to be divisible by 9
because 9 9 is equal to 3 times 3 so to
be divisible by 9 you have to be
divisible by it by 3 at least twice at
least two threes have to go into your
number and this isn't the case so you
could already knock nine out but if we
didn't already know that we're not
divisible by 3 the other way to do it is
a very similar way to figure out
divisible by divisibility by 3 and we
can add the digits so you add 3 + 8 + 0
and you get 11 and you say is this
divisible by 9 and you say this is not
divisible by 9 so 380 must not be
divisible by 9 and for 3 you do the same
thing but you test whether the sum is
divisible by 3 for 9 you test with a
certain is 1 by 9 so last Li we have the
number 10 we have the number 10 and this
is in some level the easiest one what do
all the multiples of 10 look like 10 20
30 40 we could just keep going on and on
they all end with zero or if something
ends with zero it is divisible by 10 380
is the visit does end with zero or it's
once place does have a zero on it so it
is divisible by 10 so we're divisible by
all of these numbers except for 3 6 & 9